bon
[Musique]
oui
églantine eméyé diriez vous que la prise
en charge de l'autisme s'est améliorée
depuis 2014 et votre documentaire mon
fils un si long combat qui raconte votre
quotidien avec deux enfants marco et ça
me sami et ans polyhandicapé est-ce que
ça s'est amélioré de oui quand même
honnêtement je trouve aujourd'hui pour
les familles c'est plus facile de
trouver des prises en charge le
diagnostic surtout plus rapide après ça
reste quand même très très compliqué
dans la foulée ce documentaire de plus
bien livre déchirant le voleur de
brosses à dents ou vous revenir en
détail sur cette odyssée car c'est une
odyssée en soi un voyage dont on revient
à jamais transformé
comme trop souvent toute la nuit samy
haikel
depuis huit jours il ne se nourrit que
de rares yaourt
[Musique]
oh
c'est mon quotidien depuis huit ans
[Musique]
je suis impuissante face à son mal être
pardon vous oui j'ai toujours du mal
aujourd'hui m'avait pourtant je vis
encore de ce genre d'épisode avec un
enfant qui est maintenant un ado qui est
grand donc il a 16 ans à l'époque du
film sami à 8 ans sauf est confronté
directement vous handicape on peut
difficilement imaginer ce que représente
être la mère d'un enfant autiste sévère
c'est un gymkhana autant dire
l'ascension de l'annapurna en tongs
d'autant que rien mais absolument rien
n'est fait pour aider les parents dans
une telle situation ça qui est fou alors
ça c'est sûr que moi j'étais tombé de
haut quand j'ai quand j'ai compris que
mon fils était handicapé qu'on a posé le
mot qui était déjà assez violent a fallu
attendre très longtemps pour que des
médecins pose des mots sur vos
inquiétudes pour obtenir un diagnostic
c'est tout simplement c'est fou alors
c'est fou c'était très long mais parce
que les médecins ont l'habitude de vous
dire qu'un enfant qui se développe pas
comme l'autre comme le petit copain à
côté chaque enfant se développe à son
rythme en fait
on voit bien la différence quand on est
parents et on a vite conscience qui se
passe quelque chose de pas normal et
évidemment on n'a pas envie qu'on nous
confirme cette intuition donc les
médecins qui vous disiez rien tout va
bien vous avez envie de les croire et
puis vous patienter encore une semaine
un mois de plus c'est finalement vous
allez au revoir un autre c'est très très
long et après bien après quand le mot
vous tombe dessus spontanément vous vous
dites bon ben c'est violent mais il ya
sans doute un chemin on aurait établi
mais en fait non là c'est énormément de
solitude j'aurais revient sur l'errance
médicale parce que j'ai le sentiment que
c'est encore une constante quasiment
aujourd'hui alors il ya eu des choses
quand même qui ont été faites pour le
diagnostic de l'autisme pour que les
rendez vous se débloque plus vite pour
des jeunes enfants mais encore faut-il
évidemment que les parents pensent à
l'autisme que leur médecin leur pédiatre
ou leur médecin généraliste pense or
beaucoup ne sont pas formés et c'est
bien le problème moi j'ai une soeur
médecin elle m'a dit franchement dans
tout mon cursus j'ai dû entendre parler
de l'autisme à un moment où au détour
d'une phrase pendant un cours donc je
n'en sais je n'y connais rien or un
enfant sur cent répond au diagnostic de
l'autisme oui aujourd'hui ça semble
énorme je pense que c'est aussi un
diagnostic qu'on donne à des tas de
trucs qu'on ne comprend pas son sac les
chiffres gonflent très très vide en ce
moment mais cela dit il ya aussi une
difficulté dans le diagnostic de
l'autisme c'est qu'ils sont tous
différents comment expliquez vous que la
france soit à ce point à la traîne par
rapport à d'autres pays notamment je
pense à la grande bretagne à la belgique
ou même les états unis où les prises en
charge éducative et les méthodes
comportementales il ya tout un acronyme
abattait que le sdm ou le programme
pacte développé par une orthophoniste
dans les années 2000 qui ont fait leurs
preuves pourquoi on n'a pas ces outils
là en france à l'argent parce qu'on a
une façon de faire qui est très
compliqué d'abord on a pris beaucoup de
retard parce que on est un pays pétri de
psychanalyse et que pendant longtemps
les psion penser que le problème de nos
enfants étaient un problème relationnel
entre la mère et l'enfant vous n'a pas
eu le droit à comme d'autres mères
d'enfants autistes à ce couplet sur la
culpabilité de la mer qui n'aiment
recréer le lien unit tarot en revanche
on vous a quand même expliquez vous
aviez été une mauvaise mère alors
c'était un peu après une fois que j'ai
été comme on fait c'était pris en charge
par des éducateurs spécialisés
et là on est rentré dans quelque chose
de très très compliqué ou où chaque
geste chaque réaction que j'avais avec
mon fils devait être soumise à des
protocoles très très précis donc si je
ne faisais pas au moment précis qu'on
m'avait appris à faire et bien en rouge
henriette où tout le processus
d'éducation et je faisais mal et que
confié monfils à mes parents c'était pas
bien parce que mes parents n'étaient pas
formés enfin tout était très compliqué
donc oui j'ai été accusé aussi de
beaucoup de choses sans compter que j'ai
testé avec lui fin j'ai tenté des
méthodes parce que parce que je
cherchais d espérer atteindre activation
et qu'on m'accusait de vouloir lui faire
du mal en fait mais pourquoi la france
est à la traîne point question de leur
idole pendant longtemps on a pensé que
c'était un problème si et que ensuite
toutes les méthodes dont vous avez parlé
qu'il nous apporte énormément ils sont
assez efficaces en tout cas pour donner
des moyens de communication à nos
enfants en france on accepte rien avant
d avoir testé scientifiquement validées
après des années d c'est donc il ya
beaucoup de méthodes qu'on n'a pas le
droit officiellement d'utiliser nos
parents on le fait mais en douce ouais
on a coutume d'entendre que plus tôt un
enfant et des gnostiques et plus vite il
est prise en charge plus grande sur ses
marges de progression et d'autonomie est
ce que ça aurait pu être le cas pour
samy le diagnostic il n'a pas été posée
si tardivement et j'ai mis en place des
tas de choses mais j'ai eu un autre
problème qui est encore récurrents
aujourd'hui c'est que avec le retard
qu'on a pris trouver des personnes bien
formées c'est pas évident et vous tombez
comme ça sur des psychologues ou des
éducateurs qui se disent professionnels
de telle ou telle méthode en ayant juste
suivi de trois heures de formation est
en fait vous allez dans le mur c'est
contre-productif et moi c'est ce qui
m'est arrivé vous avez découvert un
l'avc puis l'épilepsie puis l'hémiplégie
du côté gauche et le trouble autistique
de samy un peu au fur et à mesure et au
gré des rendez vous médicaux et
paramédicaux est ce que vous diriez que
ça a été un cataclysme à fragmentation
lente ou moto couchée dans un monde rêvé
dans un autre nom chez moi ça a été
assez long d'abord parce que les
diagnostics ont été posées alors assez
proches sur l'avc l'épilepsie mais après
les troubles autistiques sont venus un
petit peu plus tard aujourd'hui ça me à
16 ans il vient de faire un irm maudit
finalement il ya peut-être jamais eu
d'avc vous voyez c'est en perpétuel
questionnement en fait ce qu'il a les
troubles autistiques sont la très sévère
mais ma compréhension à moi de du niveau
de handicap a été longues parce que
finalement les professionnels sont assez
rares à mettre les mots dessus quand ils
le font en général d'ailleurs ils le
font de façon très maladroite et je
crois que c'est un parcours aussi intime
et personnel d'accepter les difficultés
de votre enfant moi j'essaie je n'ai
cessé pendant des années d'avoir des
espoirs que je diminuer petit à petit
sans réaliser à quel point de toute
façon il ne pourrait jamais faire ce que
j'imagine qu avez-vous compris que les
dommages cérébraux de samy et est
irréversible tardivement je crois
vraiment très tardivement il devais
avoir 7 ans 8 ans peut-être où je me
souviens que je sortais et j'avais une
amie psychologue avec moi et je on était
dehors et entre un jardin la rue et puis
peut-être un café j'étais là à tout en
justifier expliquer aux gens excusez moi
mais c'est parce qu'il est handicapé et
à un moment il m'a dit églantine arrête
en fait c'est hyper visible que son fils
est handicapé ça saute aux yeux et pour
moi ça ne l'était pas et je cherchais à
justifier tout en me disant que c'était
presque transitoire qu'il allait réussir
à faire des progrès peu de familles
résistent à un tel cataclysme diriez
vous que c'est cela aussi qui a eu
raison de votre couple l'arrivée d'un
enfant déjà normal dans un couple c'est
parfois difficile ça remet en question
beaucoup de choses et un fonctionnement
fonctionner à 3 c'est pas comme
fonctionner à 2 il faut encore garder du
temps pour l'autre avec un enfant
handicapé vous l'avez plus dedans c'est
que là il faut se jeter dans la bataille
à corps perdu et c'est sain c'est
tellement prenant que vous n'avez plus
le temps de vous retrouver à 2 vous êtes
donc retrouvés seuls églantine eméyé
avec deux enfants dont elles ont la vue
qui à mesure qu'il grandit se frappent
s'auto mutile et ne dort que trois
heures par nuit comment vous êtes vous
accommoder à la fois de sa souffrance et
de votre impuissance à le soulager mais
en fait je crois que je me suis jamais à
commana
jeu la souffrance de samy elle m'est
intolérable c'est je disais et je le dis
je veux bien accepter son handicap je
veux bien qu'il devienne jamais comme
vous et moi qui n'est pas un métier qui
n'est pas d'amis qui ne parlent pas mais
je veux qu'ils soient bien je veux pas
qu'il soit en souffrance permanente et
c'est là aussi où je criais au désespoir
et au scandale c'est que je pense que
même en les images que vous avez vu elle
vous choque moi elle me blesse
profondément sont des choses que j'ai
vécues tout les toutes les nuits que je
vis encore parfois
et c'est intolérable de nous laisser
nous seuls parents à gérer des nuits
pareil c'est à dire je à se battre
physiquement contre son propre enfant
pour qu'il ne se fasse pas mal c'est
impossible les structures offrant ce
sont quasiment inexistantes il y en a
très peu et on est très très nombreux à
me demander des places et puis parfois
on a des places dans des structures
qu'on estime vieillotte qui fonctionne
comme il ya sans doute 30 ans et qui ne
sont plus du tout moderne et c'est parce
qu'on veut pour nos enfants donc
évidemment il ya des familles qui les
refusent moi même j'en ai refusé alors
on va le voir mais concrètement ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que pour vivre
avec ses mille et huit premières années
de sa vie vous avez dû molletonné les
murs de sa chambre mais donner des repas
dans une piscine gonflable que vous
installiez sommiers du salon vous
couriez effectivement les médecins les
hôpitaux les urgences grâce à qui ou à
quoi l'on tient dans ces conditions
est-ce que vous avez la foi le feu sacré
une botte secrète est ce que quand j'ai
vu le film c'est très très très très
violent très très dur j'ai dû le corps
est
en jeu oui j'ai dû le corps et parce que
le réalisateur que j'avais choisi pour
prendre les images quand on s'est
retrouvé en montage même la première
journée que j'avais trouvé ça me je me
disais mais c'est pas possible sans la
caméra c'est pas lui
c'est trop facile et je lui ai dit ça la
fin de la journée il m'a regardé
atterrir mais je crois que tu n'as plus
du tout le même niveau de curseur que
moi moi je suis profondément choqué mais
est donc évidemment il ya des images que
lui a estimé qu'on ne pouvait pas mettre
qui pour moi était presque banal comme
quoi par exemple
il est souvent sans à force de se
frapper
parfois il se quand il quand il a
vraiment mal il s'auto mutile de façon
très violente et il se mord jusqu'au
sang aussi face à peu il se fait vomir
il ya beaucoup de choses qui
effectivement visuellement était pas
très très plaisante à voir mais comment
tient je pense que j'ai découvert que
j'étais sans doute bien plus solide que
j'ai imaginé il ya quelque chose qui est
en moi une nature
et puis je crois que il ya d'abord cette
enfant qui l innocence même qui arrivent
et qui est déjà blessé en tant que maman
vous ne pouvez pas ne rien faire est
assurée et puis il ya un autre enfant il
ya un autre enfant qui est la rko
marcocchi qui lui a droit à une maman
normale et à un peu de vie à la maison
et la gaieté et je pense que si
peut-être que si je ne l'avais pas eu
j'aurais moins bien tenus être obligés
tous les jours de sourire de m'amuser
avec lui d'inventer des jeux de lui
faire faire des choses banales m'a sans
doute aidé oui avez-vous eu le sentiment
comme isabelle tchoungui d'avoir été
maltraité par un système sensé au
contraire vous aider j'ai eu parfois le
sentiment d'être mal traité mais surtout
le sentiment d'être totalement
abandonnés ou livré à vous-même
complètement moi j'ai des souvenirs il
ya des moments en crise ou quand j'étais
mais désespérée à bout le week-end
quelque chose de terrible pour nous les
familles c'est
ccd d'être livré seul à nous mêmes avec
notre enfant pendant 48 heures c'est
très angoissant parfois et là vous
n'avez plus personne qui vous répond
j'ai le souvenir d'un d'une psychiatre
qui m'avait donné des médicaments mais
on va essayer des calmants et en fait ça
ne marchait pas du tout et ça me je me
réveille sami je me réveille disons que
je entre deux de réveil sami est en sang
et la laube c'est son petit frère qui
arrivent ils nous voient j'étais en
larmes son frère continuer à hurler et
c'est sami c'est marco qui me dit maman
je vais appeler mamoun qu'elles viennent
nous aider c'est impossible pour un
enfant comme ça et j'appelle la
psychiatre et elle répond pas alors
qu'elle m'avait promis qu'elle
répondrait pendant le week-end et les
hôpitaux gecko combien de fois je suis
allé aux urgences pour créer médecins
finissent par me dire mais madame vous
fichez du monde je vois vous passez
votre vie dans les hôpitaux votre fils
va très bien au revoir donc c'était
vraiment un abandon fait c'est très
difficile ils les structures d'accueil
sont quasi inexistantes en 2007 vous
décidé de créer une association un pas
vers la vie et dans son sillage une
école expérimentale pour des enfants
comme ça me oui j'avais rencontré
d'autres parents à force qui était aussi
démuni que moi et on avait décidé de se
serrer les coudes et de créer quelque
chose qu'on voulait puisque ça
n'existait papineau enfants ils sont
près nulle part en fait ça veut dire
votre fils chez vous tout le temps c'est
très compliqué d'aller travailler et on
s'est serré les coudes on a cherché des
fonds à trouver une structure on a monté
notre petite école de rêve où nos
enfants en fonction des eaux de nos
horaires un parent vous voulez aller
travailler à 6 heures du matin ont
trouvé une éducatrice qui voulaient bien
6 heures du matin et jusqu'à l'heure que
vous voulez le soir c'était très sympa
ça nous a permis de souffler et de
remettre un peu de joie cette solidarité
moi je n'en n'ai que des bons souvenirs
créer des structures lever des fonds
alerter l'opinion publique comme la ffa
se bat pour une meilleure prise en
charge est-ce que c'est aussi une façon
de se tenir et de tenir pour ne pas
céder au découragement
je n'ai fait spontanément parce que je
crois qu'au départ ce que je voulais moi
c'était que le handicap de sa mine soit
pas un tabou ni pour moi ni pour son
frère je voyais pas pourquoi je devais
en avoir honte vous nous cachez donc je
peux être que du coup je faisais l'excès
inverse j'en parlais très volontiers
après je crois que j'ai sans doute voulu
faire c'est donner une raison à ce qui
nous arrive et que cette histoire de
samy soit pas vaine je trouve que cet
enfant même si aujourd'hui il va mieux
ça reste fragile je trouve que c'est
beaucoup de souffrance j'ai du mal à me
dire que c'est une vie qui vaut la peine
d'être vécue même si tous les
professionnels me le dise je trouve que
c'est toujours tellement fragile il faut
tellement peu de choses pour qu'il
bascule et que ça et tout aille mal
qu'il faut que tout ça ne soit pas vain
et si son histoire à lui peut en avoir
aidé d'autres bien tant mieux alors vous
étiez déjà très occupé avec sami avec
l'école qui était un succès jusqu'à ce
que le ministère de la santé là ça c'est
extraordinaire jusqu'à ce que le
ministère de la santé s'y intéressent et
le confier à un organisme indépendant en
fait oui c'est moi je courais après
l'argent pour le faire fonctionner en
mode privé finalement le ministère de la
santé me dis bonne cause ce que vous
faites c'est intéressant on va vous le
financier à titre expérimental pendant
cinq ans mais moi je n'étais qu'une
petite association il faut un
gestionnaire spécialisé j'en rencontre
la rs leur encontre dit banco on vous
donne l'argent est là c'est parti de mal
en pis oui en fait très très vite on m'a
expliqué au sein de l'école que mon fils
qui était le plus sévèrement handicapé
remettait en cause le fonctionnement du
service et que c'était plus sa place
j'étais devenu un problème une intruse
une intruse et puis comme en plus
j'étais en gros j'étais moi celle qu'il
avait créé franchement j'étais le grain
de sable dans leur organisation et ça
s'est très mal terminée alors
effectivement vous avez claqué la porte
de cette structure que vous avez créées
en chasse d'une autre structure et le
mot chasse est employé à dessein extrait
je vous appelle je suis la maman d'un
petit garçon polyhandicapé mon enfant il
a il aura 8 ans au mois d'août
à
partir de
là
pourquoi même dps ne sais pas
oui mais les listes et s'établissement
je suppose que ça il n'est pas donné
n'importe quoi ils ont donné en sanction
consiste quand même
je ne retrouve pas votre dossier donc on
l'a pas reçue à étudier votre dossier
vous habitez à quel endroit madame dont
paris à paris c'est pour ça qu'on a pas
reçus votre dossier qu est ce qu est ce
que vous êtes un secteur mais il n'y a
rien compris
oui
[Musique]
et en moyenne chaque année les verts
combien de classes
alors résumons la mdph censé vous aider
vous renvoie vers six établissements on
pourrait penser que c'est byzance
seulement c'est tout le contraire aucun
n'est en mesure d'accueillir ça me soit
être jeunes sous est trop vieux soit il
n'est pas sectorisant mais ce que
j'adore kafkaïen c'est que c'est à nous
de les appeler une par une or et mais
des fois je me dis mais est-ce qu'ils
sont vidés de ce que c'est que notre
quotidien il faut en plus que je me
coltine mois tous les appels pourquoi
ils le font pas pour nous dire voilà il
ya une place pour vous à tel endroit
alors ça a progressé depuis quand même
j'ai de plus en plus souvent affaire à
des parents qui ont des propositions
plus en adéquation
après il le problème c'est toujours le
manque de structures me dis que même les
pages qu'il n'y a même pas de toilettes
pour les handicapés c'est la maison des
handicapés la première fois que j'y suis
allé avec mon fils en cours de rendez
vous j'ai demandé loto les jeux se
sentait que sa couche était sale et à
l'état joue en était n'y avait pas de
toilettes pour handicapés non mais c'est
comme ça tous les jours je suppose qu'il
existe des établissements privés en fait
ce sont des associations privées mais
qui fonctionne avec le financement de
l'état pour un enfant n'a pas le droit
de les mettre en internat par exemple
dans le privé moi j'ai essayé parce que
aujourd'hui on développe de plus en plus
d'habitants inclusif donc ce sont des
petites structures comme des maisons moi
je rêve de ça au nom de quoi parce que
nos enfants sont handicapés ils doivent
vivre forcément avec 30 camarades sur un
étage c'est pas ça on veut et puis papa
des lits d'hôpitaux et je rêve de ça et
ses maisons malheureusement j'ai demandé
je suis allé jusqu'au conseil d'état et
tout mais avec un enfant mineur vous
n'avez pas le droit il faut qu'il soit
pris en charge dans quelque chose au
moins financés surveillé par l'état ce
que je comprends aussi mais là il n'y a
pas de casse et on en ouvre par c'est
donc un parcours du combattant sans
issue que vous résumer très bien d'une
phrase je m'épuise à bâtir ce que les
institutions ne veulent pas faire oui
c'est ça et je trouve insupportable
qu'on me dise qui m'est déjà arrivé plus
d'une fois
vous en avez déjà fait un fait tant
d'autres d'établissement alors oui j'en
ai fait d'autres depuis mes
schémas bien je vais me reposer beaucoup
de maires n'ont pas d'autre choix que de
s'arrêter de travailler pour s'occuper
de leurs enfants vous vous avez fait le
choix inverse c'est de continuer à
travailler sachant que les soins sont
ruineux sont très coûteux alors oui
parce que moi je sami il a un taux de
dépendance il est considéré comme
dépendant à 80% et quand vous avez un
enfant autiste est sévère vous pouvez
pas le laisser une minute tout seul il
ya eu des périodes quand même aller aux
toilettes pour moi c'était compliqué j
allais en courant et et donc qu'il me
fallait payer quelqu'un il me faut une
éducatrice jeu si je dois partir le
matin à 8 heures du matin et que je
rentre à 19 heures il faut quelqu'un qui
soit là donc souvent d'eux c'est une
personne à temps plein donc vous compter
avec les charges c'est au minimum trois
mille euros par mois consacré votre
enfant donc c'est très très ruineux il
ya des aides maintenant meilleure mais
c'est difficile d'obtenir autant quand
même mais honnêtement là dessus les mdph
ont fait de gros progrès j'entends
beaucoup plus de dead
fiable qui sont données pour vous le
travail c'était une planche de salut
c'était la seule façon de ne pas
restreindre notre environnement au
handicap oui je crois que je serais
devenue folle et surtout enfin
dépressive je sais pas je n'aurais pas
pu se passer 24 heures sur 24 avec mon
fils je suis en admiration totale avec
les maires qui le font elles se forment
elles deviennent les éducatrices de
leurs enfants
j'y arrivais pas moi j'avais j'ai besoin
sans doute égoïstement aussi mais j'ai
besoin de me satisfaire d'autres choses
intellectuellement socialement je ne
pouvais pas vivre voilà tout le temps
avec mon fils en 2013 vous décidez
églantine de placer ses amis dans un
hôpital spécialisé à 900 km de chez vous
alors c'est une bonne base oui ça a été
évidemment une décision très très
compliqué parce que jamais j'avais
imaginé que mon fils en irait à 8 ans
et puis même qu'il s'en ira tout court
je crois que je me projetais tellement
pas julio jour le jour mais c'était
quelque chose que j'entendais que je
recevais de plus en plus souvent il faut
le placer je déteste ce mot il faut le
mettre en institution je hais ce mois et
puis ça me revenait tout le temps et sam
attaquer et en fait je me bouche et les
oreilles je voulais pas entendre et je
l'envisageais pas du tout jusqu'au jour
où un ami médecin avec qui je
travaillais à marcel rufo un jour m'a
dit mais regarde dans quel état tu es un
moment tu ne servira plus à rien pour
ton fils non plus et puis tu en as un
autre et il m'a obligé à aller voir un
psychiatre
qui m'a laisser pleurer dans son cabinet
pendant six mois et qui m'a permis de
comprendre que je me mentais beaucoup à
moi même je me trouvais d'état de
mauvaises raisons de ne pas envoyer sami
ailleurs et au même moment ça me
montrait tous les jours que la prise en
charge que j'avais organisé pour lui ne
lui convenait pas ce qui était sur
commande et je voulais pas voir non plus
vu le mal que je m'étais étonné je pense
qu'une part de moi refusait le signe
qu'il me disait il se faisait vomir
toute la journée donc il était
hospitalisé pendant qu'ils étaient à
l'hôpital dans un endroit unique en fait
où le matin on l'emmenait plus voir tel
spécialiste et il allait beaucoup mieux
il allait beaucoup mieux et c'était
épouvantable mais en même temps le signe
est éloquent la décision vous avez
prises vous l'avez prise pour samy mais
aussi pour préserver son frère aîné oui
vous pouvez pas imaginer à quel point la
fratrie est impactée moi j'ai l'habitude
de dire quand je vais plaider la cause
du handicap dit mais est ce que vous
vous rendez compte qu'à force de ne pas
vouloir financer la prise en charge
d'une personne un jour c'est tout le
monde que vous aurez mais moi je finirai
en dépression et mon fils aussi et
personne ne sera en état de travailler
donc c'est pas un coût pour la société
stran investissement s'il faut parler
comme ça mais oui j'ai réalisé un jour
peut-être chez le psychiatre qui en fait
pour essayer de sauver une vie il y en
avait deux autres qui étaient massacrés
en particulier celle de mon fils aîné ne
méritait pas ça non qu'il fallait
trouver quelque chose de plus équilibrée
entre nos trois j'imagine que j'ai bien
évidemment vu les films reinmann bien
sûr gilbert grippe qui traite du
handicap et de la fratrie à la sauce
hollywoodienne on se demande forcément
quand on pense à votre histoire comment
marco a été impactée
alors je vais vous dire très franchement
pendant longtemps quand vous lui posez
la question lui disais mais moi tout va
bien je ne suis pas impacter puisque je
n'ai connu que ça c'est ma vie et c'est
normal pour moi et puis moi je sentais
bien à l'adolescence des choses se
découvre je trouvais de plus en plus
fragile et aujourd'hui en dehors de
l'anxiété climatique qu'il a c'est un
jeune homme qui qui est très anxieux
naturellement qui va pas hyper bien et
qui est aujourd'hui suivie aussi et là
le médecin me parle de troubles post
traumatiques
et je pense qu'effectivement il a vécu
beaucoup de scènes pro violente à un âge
où c'est pas normal et ça ressort
maintenant donc il faudra le traité lui
aussi donc il a besoin d'être sur sammy
a passé cinq ans faute de mieux dans cet
établissement aujourd'hui où est il
aujourd'hui il est toujours dans le var
mais il est dans une maison de soleil
oui au soleil c'est déjà pas mal mais
dans une maison d'accueil spécialisée
parce que il était passé à un âge
adolescents où il a changé de service il
n'avait plus la place ils se
retrouvaient à quatre par chambre ce qui
pour un autiste sévère s'est révélé
d'autres sont donc j'ai trouvé autre
chose et il est dans un endroit beaucoup
plus apaisé ils sont dans des petites
unités ça c'est pas mal aussi sont
seulement 15 même si je trouve que c'est
trop encore mais il a sa chambre sa
propre salle de bain il ya suffisamment
d espace pour que s'il n'a pas envie
d'être dans la salle commune qui la
grèce parce qu'il ya trop de monde mais
il se retire c'est où sont les espaces
calme donc ça lui convient beaucoup
mieux églantine dernier vous que cette
expérience vous a laminé au contraire
augmenté non je dirais qu'elle va
augmenter
de manière très surprenante pour moi moi
j'étais j'étais celle qu'on disait être
timide très réservé sage
je suis capable de rue dans les
brancards maintenant je pense que je
suis beaucoup plus optimiste
curieusement et joyeuse que je le
montrais ou que je ne l'était
je ne savais pas que j'étais aussi
combative et donc non il m'a révélé
cette expérience vous a également ouvert
aux autres puisque vous êtes devenu
familles d'accueil pour les migrants et
abusent c'est pour des étrangers qui
forcément ne parlent pas notre langue de
la manière que sami au fond ne parle pas
non plus notre langue oui alors ça c'est
c'était pas prévu un non plus à bien une
forme de jeu de miroirs oui complètement
qui m'a surprise moi-même mais
effectivement bas il y a eu toute cette
période où on entendait tellement parlé
il ya quelques années des migrants qui
arrivait déjà en masse et d'un moment on
se disait quand même on est là dans
nouveau canapé bien confortable c'est un
peu dur et c'est pas très juste et on a
accueilli comme ça mohamed qui est venu
vivre plusieurs mois la maison ça a été
cocasse ça a été long mais c'était une
expérience formidable aussi
enrichissante je pense pour lui que pour
nous on a tous fait des efforts et ça
c'est merveilleusement bien passé quand
ils voient envie de dire aux familles
qui sont confrontées au handicap et
livré effectivement elle même j'ai envie
de leur dire osé demander de l'aide
il faut pas être orgueilleux dans ces
situations j'ai trop souvent entendu
parler de je veux pas qu'on ait pitié de
moi ou mon enfant on s'en fout
honnêtement on s'en fout le parcours il
est long il va falloir contiennent
pendant des années et des années et
aujourd'hui nos enfants handicapés ils
ont la même espérance de vie vous et moi
donc il faut qu'on tienne sur la
longueur pour bien les accompagner et
pour ça il faut qu'on se fasse aider
donc il faut oser demander de l'aide il
faut savoir où la chercher ça s'est
compliqué et dont j'ai envie de leur
dire n'hésitez pas à rejoindre des
associations
merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]